even you a show forever yeah and it's
with the very talented Maya Rudolph and
you're working with her again a very
hilarious ly funny here's my question
there's a lot of mystery around this
show there's a lot of you guys aren't
saying much about what the show entails
yeah and on purpose because there's
stuff you don't want to give away yeah
so it is a real case of this sort of
spoiler alert thing where we're just
we're also not supposed to talk about it
so whenever we do press for it whenever
were to do interviews I just don't I
don't have to say anything it's great I
just say the show is called forever it's
with Maya Rudolph and that's it
and that's why it's probably like doing
press for an upcoming Star Wars movie
where you're not allowed to say anything
you know you just must be easy like yep
can't say JJ Abrams says we can't say
that's it we're I think this is a wrap
and I wanted you know a doughnut and
then you're done that's it although I've
never been in a Star Wars movie
you have the sympathy of a nation do you
do can you we're gonna show a clip can
you tell us anything about the clip oh
yeah so I'm asking you guys not to look
at the clip you know sound - yeah let's
just turn away when we come back what's
not discuss it
okay okay so we're just going to show
the clip and we will say nothing about
it yes and no it's a it's from our show
called forever it's with Maya Rudolph
and we're on here going over stuff that
we established already that's as far as
I think that's so far as you can go
alright let's take a look as clip from
forever I think my contact lens fell out
yeah it's not in there I'm not used to
these things you can't have gone far
right around here I'll find it
no no let me I'll look for it so wet
down here disgusting oh is a fingernail
yeah well it's a boot rental place
that's probably Antonio oh wait horn
what I think I actually feel it in there
yeah it's stuck up under the lid
question I just deduced the whole arc of
the show from that I know exactly what's
gonna happen forever is now streaming on
Amazon Prime video Fred come live here
anytime you want obviously in this
studio we'd love to have thanked you
right
[Applause]
you